the following is a conversation with
vitalik buterin
co-creator of and author of the white
paper the launched ethereum and ether
which is a cryptocurrency that is
currently the second largest digital
currency after bitcoin
ethereum has a lot of interesting
technical ideas that are defining the
future of blockchain technology and
vitalik is one of the most brilliant
people innovating in the space today
unlike satoshi nakamoto the unknown
person or group that created bitcoin
vitalik is
very well known
and
at a young age it's thrust into the
limelight as one of the main faces of
the technology that may redefine the
nature of money and all forms of digital
transactions in the 21st century
this is the artificial intelligence
podcast if you enjoy it subscribe on
youtube review it with five stars in
apple podcast support on patreon or
simply connect with me on twitter alex
friedman spelled f-r-i-d-m-a-n
as usual i'll do one or two minutes of
ads now and never any ads in the middle
that can break the flow of the
conversation i hope that works for you
and doesn't hurt the listening
experience
quick summary of the ads two sponsors
masterclass and
expressvpn
please consider supporting the podcast
by signing up to masterclass and
masterclass.com
lex
and getting expressvpn at expressvpn.com
lex
pod
this show is sponsored by masterclass
sign up at masterclass.com lex to get a
discount and to support this podcast
when i first heard about masterclass i
honestly thought it was too good to be
true
for 180 a year you get an all-access
pass to watch courses from experts at
the top of their field
to list some of my favorites
chris hadfield on space exploration neil
degrasse tyson on scientific thinking
and communication will write the creator
of simcity and sims on game design
i love that game
jane goodall on conservation carlos
santana one of my favorite guitarists on
guitar gary kasparov on chess obviously
i'm russian i love gary
daniel negrano on poker one of my
favorite poker players also phil ivey is
uh gives a course as well and many many
more
chris hadfield explaining how rockets
work and the experience of being
launched into space alone is worth the
money
by way of advice for me the key is not
to be overwhelmed by the abundance of
choice
pick three courses you want to complete
watch each all the way through from
start to finish it's not that long but
it's an experience that will stick with
you for a long time i promise
it's easily worth the money you can
watch it on basically any device
once again
sign up at masterclass.com
lex to get a discount and to support
this podcast
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
download it at expressvpn.com
lex pod to get a discount and to support
this podcast
i've been using expressvpn for many
years
i honestly love it
it's easy to use
press the big power on button and your
privacy is protected and if you like you
can make it look like your location is
anywhere else in the world i might be in
boston now but i can make it look like
i'm in new york london paris or anywhere
else
this has a large number of obvious
benefits
for example certainly it allows you to
access international versions of
streaming websites like the japanese
version of netflix or the uk version of
hulu
as you probably know i was born in the
soviet union so sadly given my roots and
appreciation of russian history and
culture my website and the website for
this podcast is blocked in russia
so this is another example of where you
can use expressvpn to access sites like
the podcast
that are not accessible in your country
expressvpn works on any device you can
imagine i use it on linux shout out to
ubuntu
windows android but it's available
everywhere else too
once again download it at expressvpn.com
lex pod to get a discount and to support
this podcast
and now here's my conversation with
vitalik buterin
so before we talk about the fundamental
ideas behind
ethereum and cryptocurrency
perhaps it'd be nice to uh to talk about
the the origin story of bitcoin
and the uh mystery of satoshi nakamoto
you give a talk that started with
sort of asking the question what did
uh satoshi nakamoto actually invent
maybe you could say who is satoshi
nakamoto and what did he invent sure so
satoshi nakamoto is
the name by which we know the person who
originally came up with bitcoin so the
reason why i say the name by which we
know is that
this is a anonymous uh fellow who has uh
shown himself to us only um over the
internet uh just by first publishing the
white paper uh for bitcoin and then
releasing the original source code for
bitcoin and then talking to
the very early bitcoin community on
bitcoin forums and
and of interacting with them and helping
the project along for a couple of years
um and then at some point in late 2010
to early 2011 he disappeared uh so
bitcoin is uh a fairly unique project
and how it has this kind of
mythical kind of quasi-god-like founder
who just kind of popped in and did the
thing and it
disappeared and we've somehow just never
heard from him again so in 2008 was so
the white paper was the first do you
know if the white paper was the first
time the
name
would actually appear satoshi nakamoto
believe so
so how is it possible
that the creator of such a impactful
project
remains anonymous
that's a tough question and there's no
similarity to it in history of
technology as far as i'm aware yeah
so one possibility is that it's hal
finny um because uh hell finney was kind
of also
active in the bitcoin community and as
um how finney
um in those uh two
beginning years and uh how who is how
thin he may be he is one of the people
in the end of early cypherpunk community
he was
a computer scientist just yeah computer
scientists cryptographers people
interested in uh like
technology internet freedom like those
kinds of topics was it correct that i
read that he seemed to have been
involved in either the earliest or
the first transaction of bitcoin yes the
first transaction of bitcoin was between
sister oshie and alfini
do you think he knew who satoshi was if
he wasn't satoshi you probably know
how is it possible to work so closely
with people and nevertheless not know
anything about their fundamental
identity
is this like a natural sort of
characteristic of the internet
like if we were to think about it
because you and i just met now
there's a there's a depth of knowledge
that we we now have about each other
that's like physical like
my vision system is able to recognize
you i can also verify your identity of
uniqueness like yep
like it's very hard to fake you being
you yes so the internet
the internet has a fundamentally
different quality to it which is just
fascinating yeah i know this is
definitely interesting because
i
definitely just know a lot of people
just by their internet handles and like
to me when i think of them like i see
their internet handles and
one of them has enough profile pictures
this kind of
face that's kind of not quite human with
a bunch of kind of psychedelic colors in
it and when i visualize him i could just
visualize that that's not an actual face
yeah
you are the creator of the second well
he's currently the second most popular
cryptocurrency
uh ethereum so on this topic if we just
stick on satoshi nakamoto for for a
little bit longer
you may be the most qualified person to
speak to the psychology of this
anonymity that we're talking about
like
your identity is known like i've just
verified it but uh from your perspective
what are the benefits
in uh creating a cryptocurrency and then
remaining anonymous like if it can
psychoanalyze satoshi nakamoto is there
something interesting there
or is it just a peculiar quirk of him
it definitely helps create this uh kind
of image of this kind of neutral thing
that doesn't belong to anyone
and
then you've created a project
and because you're anonymous and because
uh you also have uh disappear or as
unfortunately happened to how finny if
that is him he ended up i think dying of
a lou gehrig's disease and he is in a
cryogenic freezer now but
like if you
pop in and you d and then you create it
and
and you're gone and uh
all that's remaining of uh that whole
process is the thing itself then like
no one can go and try to
um and if interpret any of your other
behavior and try to understand like oh
the
this person
wrote this thing um in some essay at age
16 where he expressed particular
opinions about democracy and so because
of that this project is like is a
statement that's trying to do this
specific thing
instead it creates uh this uh
environment where
the thing is what you make of it and
it doesn't have the yeah right the the
burden of your other ideas political
thought and so on so so now that we're
sitting with you
do you feel the burden of
being kind of the face
of ethereum i mean there's a very large
community of developers but nevertheless
yeah
is there like a burden associated with
that
there definitely is this is uh
definitely a big reason why i've been
trying to kind of push for the ethereum
ecosystem to become more decentralized
in many ways
just
encouraging a lot of kind of core
ethereum work to happen outside of the
ethereum foundation and of expanding
the number of people that are making
different kinds of decisions having
multiple software limitations instead of
one and all of these things like there's
a lot of things that i've tried to do to
and remove myself as a single point of
failure because
that is something that a lot of people
criticism
criticize me for um
so if you look at like the most
fundamentally successful open source
projects
it seems that it's like a sad reality
when i think about it is it seems to be
that one person is
a crucial contributor often you feel
like a lioness from
from uh for the for linux for the
colonel yeah that is possible and i'm
definitely not planning to disappear
that's an interesting
tension that projects like this kind of
desire a single entity
and yet
they're fundamentally distributed
i don't know if there's something
interesting to say about that kind of
structure and thinking about the future
of cryptocurrency does there need to be
a leader
there's different kinds of leaders you
know there's uh
there's dictators who control all the
money there's people who control
organizations there's uh kind of high
priests that just have themselves on
their twitter followers
what kind of leader are you would you
say
yeah in these days
actually
a bit more in the hype in the high
priest direction than before yeah like
i definitely actually don't do all that
much of kind of going around and like
ordering ethereum foundation people to
do things because i think those things
are important i if there's something
that i do think is important that you i
do just usually kind of say it publicly
or just kind of say it to people and
quite often
projects just going to start doing it
so let's ask the
high philosophical question
about money yeah what at the highest
level is money what is money
it's a kind of game and it's a game
where you know we have points and if you
have points there's this one move where
you can reduce your points by a number
and increase someone else's voice by the
same number
and
these so it's a fair game hopefully well
it's one kind of fair game
like for example you know you can have
other kinds of fair games like you're
gonna have a game where if i give
someone a point and you give someone a
points and instead of that person
getting two points that person gets four
points and that's also fair
but
no money is um
easy to kind of set up and it serves a
lot of useful functions and so it kind
of just survives in the society as a
meme for thousands of years
it's useful for this storage of wealth
it's useful for the uh exchange of value
and it's also useful for denominating
future payments
a unit of account
a unit of account so what if you look at
the history of money in human
civilization
what just uh
if if you're a student of history like
how
has this role or just the mechanisms of
money changed over time in your view
even if we just look at the 20th century
before and then leading up to
cryptocurrencies that's something you
think about
yeah and i think like the big thing in
the 20th century is kind of we saw a lot
more intermediation i guess
like you know i mean the first part is
kind of the move from
being adding more of different kinds of
banking and then i used we
saw the move from and of dollars being
backed by gold to dollars
being backed by gold that's only
redeemable by certain people the dollars
not being backed by anything um to and
it's just this uh nerf system where you
have a bunch of free floating currencies
and then
people like um getting out of bank
accounts and then those things becoming
electronic people getting accounts with
payment processors that have account um
bank accounts
so
so what what do you make of that is
that's such a fascinating philosophical
idea that money might not be backed by
anything
what is that like fascinating to you
that money can exist without being
backed by something physical
it definitely is like what do you make
of that
like
how is that possible is that stable if
we look at the future of human
civilization is it possible to have
money at the large scale at such a
hugely productive and rich societies
be able to operate successfully without
money being backed by anything physical
i feel like the interesting thing about
the 21st century especially is that
a lot of the important valuable things
are not backed by anything like if you
look at like tech companies for example
like something like twitter
like you could theoretically imagine
that if all of the employees wanted to
they could kind of come together they
would quit
and you know start working on twitter
2.0 and
then
the value of um
and just kind of build the exact the the
exact same product of course possibly
build a better product and then just
kind of continue on from there and the
original
the original twitter would kind of just
not have people left anymore right like
the
there is theoretically kind of code and
like ip that's owned by the company but
in reality like good programmers could
probably read up rewrite all that stuff
in three months
so the
like the reason why the thing has value
is just kind of network effects and
coordination problems right like these
employees in reality aren't going to
switch all at once and also the users
aren't um all going to switch them at
once because it's just difficult for
them to switch at once and so
there's these kind of
meta-stable of equilibrium in the
interactions between thousands and
millions of people that are just
actually quite sticky even though if you
try to kind of assume that everyone's a
perfectly rational and kind of perfectly
slippery spherical cow they don't seem
to exist at all
this that stickiness do you have a sense
of grasp of the
sort of the fun fundamental dynamic like
the physics of that stickiness
it seems to work but uh and i think some
of the cryptocurrency
ideas kind of rely on it working yeah
it's uh you know it's the sort of thing
that's definitely been uh economically
modeled a lot like
one uh the kind of
analogy of something as similar that uh
you often see in textbooks as like
what is a government like if for exa
like 80 percent of uh people in a
country just like tomorrow suddenly had
had the idea that like
the laws that are currently the laws in
the government that currently is the
government are just people and some and
some other thing is the government and
they just kind of start acting like it
then that will kind of become the new
reality and then the question is well
what happens if and if
between zero and 80 people or
and 80 of people start believing that
and like what is
uh the thing you also you see is that
if there is one of these kind of
switches happening this kind of
revolution then if you're the first
person to join then like you
probably probably don't have the
incentive to do that but then if you're
the 55th
percentile person to join then suddenly
becomes quite safe too and so
this definitely is the sort of thing
that you can kind of try to analyze and
understand mathematically but
one of the
kind of results is that the sort of
like
when the switch happens definitely can
be chaotic sometimes
yeah but still like to me the idea that
uh the network affects the the fact that
human beings at a scale like millions
billions can share
even the idea of currency like
all agree that's just uh
i know economics can model it i'm a
skeptic on economic and uh
it's like uh so my my favorite sort of
field maybe recreationally psychology is
trying to understand human behavior
and i i think sometimes people just kind
of pretend that they can have a grasp on
human behavior even though we it's such
a messy space that all the models that
psychology or economics those different
perspectives on human behavior can have
or
are difficult
it's difficult to know how much that's
wishful thinking and how much it is
actually getting to the core of
understanding human behavior but
on that idea
what
do you think is the role of money in
human motivation
so
do you think
money
from an economics perspective from a
psychology perspective is core
to like human desires
money is definitely very far from the
only motivator um it is a big motivator
and it's uh one of the closest things
you have to a universal motivator
i think
because ultimately in like almost any
person in the world if you
ask them to do something like they'll be
more inclined to do it if you also offer
some uh
offer the money right and that's uh
there's definitely many cases where
people will do things other than things
that maximize how much money they have
and that happens all the time but
like though a lot of those other things
are kind of but much more
specific to and of who that person is
and of what their situation is the
relationship between the motive and the
action and these other things what do
you think is in the interplay of the
other motivator from like nietzsche
perspective is power
do you think money equals power do you
think those are conflicting ideas do you
think i mean that's the one of the ideas
that decentralized currency
decentralized applications are looking
at is
who holds the power yeah
money is definitely a kind of power and
there's definitely people who
want money because it gives them power
and then
even
if my money doesn't seem to and
explicitly be about money a lot of uh
things that people spend money on are
ultimately about a social status of some
kind
um
so i mean i definitely view those two
things as kind of interplaying and then
there's also money as just a way of uh
like
measuring how successful you are i guess
a scoreboard right so this kind of gets
back to the game
like if
you have four billion dollars then
the main benefit you get from going up
well one of the big benefits you get
from going up to six million dollars is
that now instead of uh being below the
guy who has five you're above the guy
who has five
so you think money could be kind of uh
in a game of life it's also a measure of
self-worth it's like how we
it's definitely how uh
how a lot of people perceive it define
ourselves in the hierarchy of yeah and
i'm not
yeah not saying it's kind of a healthy
thing that people
define their self-worth as money because
it's definitely kind of far from a yeah
perfect indicator of like how much you
like
value you provide to society or anything
like this but i i definitely think that
like
as a matter of kind of current practice
a bunch of people do feel that way
so what does utopia from an economic
perspective look like to you
what does the perfect world look like
i guess like the economists say utopia
would be
one where
kind of
everything is an of incentive aligns in
this um in the sense that there aren't
enough conflicts between what satisfies
your goals and kind of what is uh good
for and everyone in the world um in the
world as a whole
what do you think that would um
look like does does that mean they're
still
poor people and rich people there's
still income inequality
do you think sort of uh marxist ideas
are strong do you think sort of
ideas of objectivism
uh like where the market rules is strong
like what is there is the different
economic philosophies that just
seem to be reflective of what utopia
would be
so i definitely think that
existing economic philosophies do end up
kind of
systematically kind of deviating from
the utopia in a lot of ways yeah like
one of the big things i talk about for
example is public goods right and public
goods are especially important on the
internet right yeah because
like the idea is with kind of money as
this game where you know i was a few
coins a few coins and you gain the same
number of coins is that this usually
happens in a trade where i lose some
money you gain some money you lose a
sandwich and i gain a sandwich
and
this kind of model works really well
when the thing that we're using money to
incentivize the set of private goods
right things that you provide to one
person where the benefit comes to one
person but
the
like on the internet especially but also
many many contacts kind of off the
internet there's actions that kind of
individuals or groups can take where
instead of the benefit going to one
person the benefit just goes to many
people at the same time and you can't
control who the benefit goes to right so
for example this podcast you know we
publish it
and
when it's published you don't have any
fine grains control over like oh these
38 000 people can watch it and then like
these other 29 000 people can't it's
like once the number goes high enough
then you know people will just like copy
it and then when i write articles on a
blog then
they're just like
free for everyone and that stuff's even
harder to prevent anyone from copying
so and aside from that things like you
know scientific research for example
and
even taking more pedestrian examples
like climate change mitigation would be
a big one um
so
there's a lot of things in the world
where
you have these kind of individual
actions with have concentrated costs and
distributed benefits and money as a
point system
does not do a good job of encouraging
these things
and
one of the kind of other things even
kind of
tangentially connected to crypto but
kind of theoretically outside of it that
i work on is this sort of mechanism
called quadratic funding um and the way
to think about it is and i've imagine a
point system where
if uh
like if one person gives a coin
gives coins to one other person then it
works the same way as money but if
multiple people uh give coins to one
person and they do so anonymously so
it's kind of not in consideration for a
specific service to that person
themselves and then
the number of coins received by that
person is kind of greater than just the
sum of the number of coins that have
given by those different people
um so the actual formula is you take the
square root of the amount that each
person gave then you add all the square
roots and then you had to square the
sums
yeah and then you give that and
the idea here would basically be that if
let's say for example
you just started going off and kind of
planting a lot of trees
and there's a bunch of people that are
really happy that you're planting trees
and so they go and all kind of throw a
coin um your way then
the like there is like basically the
fact that kind of you get more than the
sum you get this kind of square of some
of these of uh of square roots of these
tiny amounts is them
that this actually kind of compensates
for the tragedy of the comments right in
this there's even this kind of
mathematical proof that it sort of
optimally compensates for it what is the
tragedy of the common um this is just
this idea that
like if there is this uh situation where
there's some public good that lots of
people benefit from then no individual
person wants to contribute to it because
if they contribute they only get a small
part of the benefit from
their contribution but they pay the full
cost of their contribution
in which context does this um sorry what
is the term quadratic quadratic funding
like what's in which context is this
mechanism
useful so
obviously you said to to combat the
tragedy of the commons but yeah in which
context do you see it as useful actually
practically yeah theoretically public
goods in general right so like like
services like what what are we what are
we talking about what's the public yeah
so
within the um ethereum ecosystem for
example like we've actually tried using
this mechanism i yeah wrote a couple of
articles about the cinevon vitalic.ca
where i go through some of the most
recent rounds and it's been really
interesting um some of the top ones that
people supported there were
things like kind of just
online user interfaces that make it
easier for people to interact with
ethereum
there was
documentation there were podcasts
there were
enough software kind of clients like
kind of implementations of the ethereum
protocol of privacy tools just like
lots of things that are
useful to lots of people
when a lot of people are contributing
like funding a particular
particular entity yeah uh that's really
that's really interesting is there
something special about the quadratic
the
the the summing of the square roots yeah
so another way to think about it is like
imagine if n people each give a dollar
then the person gets n squared right um
and
and so each individual person's uh
contribution gets multiplied by n right
because you have n people yeah um and so
that kind of perfectly compensates for
the kind of kind of anti-1 uh tragedy of
the commons i just wonder if the the
squared part is yeah how fundamental no
it is um
and i'd uh recommend you go to uh on
vitalik.ca i have this article called a
quadratic payments a primer and highly
recommended it's kind of at least my
attempt so far and explaining the
intuition behind this intuition so if we
could can we go to the
the very basic
what is
the blockchain or perhaps
we might even start at the uh
the byzantine generals problem in
byzantine fault tolerance in general
that
i i
bitcoin was taking steps to uh providing
a solution for
so the byzantine generals problem it's
this uh
paper that uh leslie lamport uh
published in 1982 where he has this
thought experiments where if you have
two generals that are have camped out on
opposite sides of a city
and they're planning when to attack the
city
then
the question is and if how could those
generals coordinate with each other and
they could send message messengers
between each other but those messengers
kind of could get sniped by the enemy on
the
road some of those messages could end up
being traders and if things could end up
happening and
with just two
mess
generals it turns out that there's kind
of no solution in a finite number of
rounds that guarantees that they will be
able to coordinate on the same answer um
but then in the case where you have more
than two generals and then leslie
analyzes cases like
um are the mess and
messages kind of just oral messages are
the messages kind of signed messages so
i can give you a signed message and then
you can pass along that signed message
and the third party can still verify
that i originally made that message
and depending on those different cases
there's kind of different bounds on like
given how many generals and how many
traders um among those generals kind of
whether like under one conditions you
actually can't agree when to launch an
attack uh so
it's actually a big misconception that
the the byzantine general's problem was
unsolved so listen lanport solved it the
thing that was unsolved though is that
all of these solutions assume that
you've already agreed on a fixed list of
who the generals are and
these generals have to be kind of
semi-trusted to some extent they can't
just be anonymous people because if
they're anonymous then like the enemy
could just be 99 of the generals
so
right then
in the 1980s and the 1990s kind of the
general use case for distributed system
stuff was more kind of enterprisey stuff
where you could kind of assume
that uh you know you know who the nodes
are that are running these nf computer
networks so if you wants to have some in
a decentralized computer network that
pretends to be a single computer and
that you can kind of do
do a lot of operations on then
it's made out of these kind of 15
specific computers and we know kind of
who and where they are and so we have a
good reason to believe that say at least
11 of them would be fine
and then it could also be within a
single system exactly almost a network
of devices sensors so on like in
airplanes and i think uh like flight
systems in general still use these kinds
of ideas yep yep um so that's the 80s
that's the it is the 90s now the
cypherpunks had a different use case in
mind which is that they wanted to create
a fully a decentralized global
permissionless currency
and
the problem here is that they didn't
want any authorities and they didn't
even want any kind of privileged list of
people and so now the question is well
how
do you use these techniques to create
consensus when you have no way of kind
of measuring identities right you have
no way of
kind of determining whether or not some
99 of participants aren't actually all
the same guy
and so the clever solution that satoshi
had this is uh kind of going back to the
that presentation i made at defcon a few
months ago where i said that the thing
satoshi invented with crypto economics
is this uh really neat idea that you can
use economic resources to kind of limit
identity how many identities you can get
and
the uh
if there isn't any existing
decentralized digital currency then the
only way to do this is with proof of
work right so with proof of work the
solution is just
you
publish a solution to a hard
mathematical puzzle that takes some uh
kind of clearly calculable amount of
computational power to solve you get an
identity and then you solve five of
those puzzles you get five identities
and then these are the identities that
we run the consensus algorithm between
so the proof-of-work mechanism you just
described is like the fundamental idea
proposed in the
in the white paper that defines
bitcoin uh what's the
idea of consensus that we wish to reach
what
why is consensus
important here what is consensus
so
the goal here
in just simple technical terms is to
basically kind of wire together a set of
a large number of computers in such a
way that they yeah kind of pretends to
the outside world to be a single
computer where that single computer
keeps working even if a large portion of
the kind of constituents the computers
that make it up break and kind of break
in arbitrary ways like they could shut
off they could uh try to actively break
a system they could do lots of mean
things
so
the
reason why the cypherpunks wanted to do
this is because they wanted to run one
particular program on this virtual
computer and the one particular program
that they wanted to run is just a
currency system right it's a system that
just processes a series of transactions
and for every transaction it verifies uh
that the sender has enough coins to pay
for the transaction and verifies that
the digital signature is correct and if
the check's passed then it subtracts the
coins from one account and adds the
coins to the other account roughly
so first of all the the the
proof-of-work idea is kind of i mean at
least to me seems
pretty
fascinating it is i mean that's a
it's kind of a revolutionary idea i mean
is is it is it obvious to come up with
that you can
use uh you can exchange basically
computational resources for
for identity
it's uh it actually has a pretty long
history it was uh first proposed in a
paper by uh
cynthia dwork and
[Music]
neor in 1994 i believe and the original
use case was uh combating email spam so
the idea is that if you send an email
you have to send it with a proof of work
attached and
like this makes it reasonably cheap to
send emails to your friends but it makes
it really expensive to send spam to a
million people
yeah that's a
simple brilliant idea so maybe also
taking a step back so what is the role
of blockchain in this
what is the blockchain sure so the
blockchain
i mean my way of thinking about it is
that it is this
kind of
system where you have this kind of one
virtual computer created by this a bunch
of these uh uh nodes in the network um
and the reason why
the term blockchain is used is because
the data structure that these systems
use at least so far
is one uh where
they um even if different nodes in the
network periodically publish blocks and
a block is a kind of list of
transactions uh together with a pointer
like a hash of a yeah
a previous block that it builds on top
of
um and so you have a series of blocks
that that
nodes in the network create where each
block points to the previous block and
so you have this chain of them
is a fault tolerance
mechanism built into the idea of
blockchain or is there a lot of
possibilities of different ways to make
sure there's no
funny stuff going on there are indeed a
lot of possibilities um so in a kind of
just simple architecture as i just
described the way the fault tolerance
happens is like this right so
you have a bunch of nodes and they're
just happily and occasionally creating
blocks building on top of each other's
uh blocks
and let's say you have kind of one block
we'll call it kind of block one
and then
someone else builds another block on a
steel called block two
then we have an attacker and what the
attacker tries to do is the attacker
tries to revert block two and the way
they revert block two is instead of
doing the thing they're supposed to do
which is build a block on top of block
two they're gonna build another block on
top of block one um so you have block
one which has two children block two and
then block two prime now
this might sometimes even happen by
random chance if you know two nodes in
the network just happen to create blocks
at the same time and they don't hear
about each other's things before they
create their own but this also could
happen because of an attack
now
if this happens you have an attack then
the no in the bitcoin system uh the
nodes follow the longest chain um so if
um this um attack had happened uh and if
when the uh
original chain had more than two blocks
on it so if it was trying to kind of
revert more than more than two blocks
then everyone would just
would just ignore it yeah um and
everyone would just keep following the
regular chain but here you know we have
block two and we have block two prime
and so the two are kind of even and then
whatever block um the next block is
created on top of so say block three is
now created on top of block two prime
then everyone says
agrees that block 3 is the new head
and
block 2 prime is just kind of forgotten
and then everyone just kind of
peacefully builds on top of block 3 and
the thing continues so how difficult is
it to mess with the system
so how like if we look at the general
problem like how many
what fraction of people who participate
in the system have to be bad
players
in order to mess with it truly like
what's your is there is there a good
number serious um
well depending on kind of what your
model of the participants is and like
what kind of attack we're talking about
it's
anywhere between 23.2 and 50 percent
of what of all of the computing power in
the network
sorry so 22 and 23. between 23.2 and 50
and 50
are can be
uh compromised so like once you're once
your pers your portion of the total um
computing power the network goes above
the 23.2 level then there's kind of
things that you can mean things that you
can potentially do and as your
percentage of the network kind of keeps
going up then the your abilities as you
mean things kind of goes higher and then
if you have above 50 then you can just
break everything so how hard is it to
achieve that level like it seems that
so far historically speaking has been
exceptionally difficult
so this is a challenging question um so
the economic cost of uh acquiring that
level of stuff from scratch is uh fairly
high i think it's uh
somewhere in the low billions of dollars
and when you say that stuff you mean
computational resources yeah so
specifically specialized hardware and of
asics that people use to uh solve these
uh puzzles is to do the mining these
days small tangent uh
so obviously i work a lot in deep
learning with gpus and asics for that
application and i tangentially kind of
hear that so many of these you know
sometimes nvidia gpus are sold out
because of this other application like
what do if you can comment
i don't know if you're familiar or
interested in the space what kind of
asics what kind of hardware
is generally used these days for
to do the actual computation for the the
proof of work sure so in the case uh and
bitcoin and ethereum are a bit different
uh so in the case of bitcoin there is an
algorithm called uh
sha256 it's just a hash function and so
the puzzle is just coming up with a
number where the hash of the number is
below some threshold and so because the
hashes are
designed to be random you just have to
keep on trying different numbers until
one works
and the
are just like specialized circuits that
contain kind of
circuits for evaluating this hash over
and over again and you have like
millions or billions of these hash
evaluators since just stacked on top of
each other inside of a box and you just
keep on running the box 24 7. in the asx
there's literally specialized hardware
designed for this yes oh this is we live
in an amazing world
another tangent and i'll come back to
the basics but uh does quantum computing
throw a wrench into any of this
very good question so uh quan some
computers have two main kind of families
of algorithms that are relevant to
cryptography one is a shores algorithm
ensures algorithm is one that kind of
completely breaks the hardness of uh
some specific kinds of mathematical
problems so the one that you've probably
heard of is it makes it very easy to
factor numbers uh so like figure out
kind of what prime factors are that kind
of that you need to multiply together to
get some number even if that number is
extremely big um sure's algorithm can
also be used to break elliptic curve
cryptography
um it can break like any kind of hidden
order group so
it breaks a lot of kind of cryptographic
nice things that we're used to
but the good news is that for every kind
of major use of uh things that shore's
algorithm breaks we already know of uh
quantum proof alternatives right now we
don't use these quantum proof
alternatives yet because in many cases
they're five to ten times what's
efficient but and uh the
crypto
industry in general kind of knows that
this is coming eventually and it's kind
of ready to uh take the head and switch
to that stuff when we when we have to
the second algorithm that is relevant to
cryptography is grover's algorithm and
and grover's algorithm might even be
kind of more familiar to ai people
that's basically usually described as
solving search problems um but the idea
here is so that if you have a problem
over the form finds a number that
satisfies some property um then if with
a classical computer you need to try
kind of end times before before you find
the number then with a quantum computer
you only need to do square root of n
computations
and grovers
could potentially be used for mining but
there's two possibilities here one is
that grovers could be used for mining
and whoever creates the first working
quantum computer that could do grovers
we'll just mine way faster than everyone
else and we'll see another round of uh
what we saw when asics came out which is
that's kind of the new hardware just
kind of dominated the old stuff and then
eventually it switched to a new
equilibrium but by the way way faster
not exponentially faster quadratically
faster quadratically faster which is not
sort of uh
it's not game-changing i would say it's
like asics like you said it would be
exactly
yeah so it would not necessarily break
proof of work as of that's right yeah
now the other
kind of possible world right is that
quantum computers have a lot of overhead
there's a lot of complexity involved in
maintaining quantum states and there's
also
as we've been realizing recently
making quantum computers requ actually
work requires kind of quantum era
correction which requires kind of a
thousand real qubits per logical qubit
and so there's the very real possibility
that the overhead of running a quantum
computer will be higher than the speed
up you get with grovers which would be
kind of sad but which would also mean
that given proof of work would just keep
working fine
so
they're beautifully put so so proof of
work
is uh the core idea of bitcoin is there
other core ideas before we kind of take
a step towards the origin story and the
ideas of ethereum is there other stuff
that uh were key to the white paper of
bitcoin there's proof of work and then
there's just the cryptography just kind
of public keys and signatures that are
used to uh verify transactions those two
really big things
so then what is um
the origin story maybe the human side
but also the technical side of ethereum
sure so i joined the bitcoin community
in uh 2011
and i started by just writing i first
wrote for this sort of online thing
called bitcoin weekly
then i started writing for uh bitcoin
magazine
um
and uh
sorry to interrupt you have this funny
kind of
uh story true or not is uh
that you were disillusioned by
the downsides of centralized control
from your experience with wow world of
warcraft is this true or you're just
being witty uh i mean the event is true
of the fact that that's the reason i do
decentralization is woody
maybe just a small tangent
d have you always had a skepticism of
centralized control
is that
some degree yeah
has that feeling evolved over time or is
that just always been a core feeling
that decentralized control is the future
of a human society
and it's definitely been something that
felt very attractive to me ever since i
could afford that such a thing as
possible possible yeah
so great so you are you join the bitcoin
community in 2011 you said you began
writing
so what was next
started writing uh
moved from high school to university
halfway in between that and spent a year
in university
um then at the end of that year i
dropped out to to do uh bitcoin things
uh full time
and this was a combination of continuing
the right bitcoin magazine but also
increasingly work on software projects
and i traveled around the world for
about six months and just going to
different bitcoin communities like i
went to uh first in new hampshire and
then spain other european voices um
israel and san francisco
and along the way and i've met a lot of
other people that are working on
different bitcoin projects and when i
was in israel there were some very smart
teams there that were working on ideas
that people were starting to kind of
call bitcoin 2.0 so one of these were
covered coins which is basically saying
that hey let's uh not just use the
blockchain for bitcoin but let's also
kind of issue other kinds of assets on
it and then there was a protocol called
mastercoin that supported issuing assets
but also supported many other things
like financial contracts like domain
name registration and a lot of different
things together
and
i
spent some time working with these teams
and i quickly kind of realized that
this mastercoin protocol could be
improved by kind of generalizing it more
right so the master the analogy i use is
that the master coin protocol was like
the swiss army knife you have
25 different transaction types for 25
different applications
but
what i realized is that you could
replace a bunch of them with things that
are more general purpose so one of them
was that you could replace
like three transaction types for three
types of financial contracts with a
generic transaction type for a financial
contract that just lets you specify a
mathematical formula for kind of who
how much money each side gets by the way
it's a small pause what's you say
financial contract just the terminology
what is the contract
um what's a financial contract so the
this is just generally an agreement
where kind of
either one or two parties kind of put
collateral kind of in um and then
they depending on and if certain
conditions like this could involve
prices of assets this could involve
different the actions of the two parties
it could involve other things
but they kind of get different amounts
of uh
of assets out that it'll just depend on
things that happened so a contract is
really a financial contract is the is at
the core it's the it's the core
interactive element of a financial
system yeah there's yeah there's many
different kinds of financial contracts
like there's things like options where
you kind of give someone the right to
buy a thing that you have for some
specific price for some period of time
there's uh
contracts for
difference where you
basically are kind of making a bet that
says like for every dollar this thing
goes up i'll give you seven dollars or
for every dollar that thing goes down
you give me seven dollars or something
like that
and but the main idea that these
contracts have to be enforced and
trusted
yes exactly
you have to trust that they will work
out in a system where nobody can be
trusted yes
this is
such a beautiful complicated system okay
so uh so you were seeking to kind of
generalize this basic uh framework of
contracts
so what does that
entail so what what technically are the
steps to creating ethereum
so i guess just to kind of continue a
bit with this master coin story sure um
so
started by end of giving ideas for how
to generalize the thing and eventually
um this turned into a much more kind of
fully fledged proposal that just says
hey how about you scrap all your
features and instead you just
um put in this programming language and
i gave this idea to them and their
response was something like hey this is
great but this seems complicated and it
seems like something that's we're not
going to be able to put onto our roadmap
for a while and my response to this was
like wait do you not realize how
revolutionary this is well just go do it
myself
and then i
was the name of the programming language
i just called it ultimate scripting
great uh so
then i
kind of went through a couple more
rounds of iteration and
then the idea for ethereum itself
started to form um and
the idea here is that you just have a
blockchain where the core unit of the
thing is what we call contracts it's
these and if accounts that can hold
assets and like like have their own
internal memory but that are controlled
by a piece of code and so
if i send some ether to a contract the
only thing that can determine where that
kind of ether and the currency inside
ethereum and it goes after that um is
the code of that contract itself and so
basically you're kind of sending assets
to computer programs becomes this kind
of paradigm for creating the incentive
agreement self-executing agreements
self-executing it's so cool that code is
sort of part of this contract
so that that's what's meant by smart
contracts yeah
so how hard was it to build this kind of
thing harder than expected um and
originally i actually thought that this
would be a thing that i would kind of
casually work on for a couple of months
publish and then go back to university
um
then
i released it and
a bunch of people or i released a white
paper white paper there is there the
idea the white paper um a whole bunch of
people came in offering to help a huge
number of people and have expressed
interest and this was something i was
totally not expecting
and
then i kind of realized that this would
be something that's kind of much bigger
than i had ever
thought that it would be and
then we started on this kind of much
longer developments log of making
something that
lives up to this sort of much higher
level of expectations what are the some
of the
is it fundamentally like software
engineering challenges it was there
social okay so there's social
so so what are the biggest interesting
challenges that you've learned about
human civilization and in software
engineering through this process
so i guess
one of the challenges for me is that
like i'm one of the kind of apparently
unusual geeks who was kind of never
treated with anything but kindness in
school yes um and so
when i
got into crypto i kind of expected
everyone would just kind of be the same
kind of altruistic and nice in that same
way um but
the um and if the algorithm that i used
for finding co-founders for this thing
was not very good it was sort of
literally one computer scientist called
the greedy algorithm it's kind of the
first 15 people who applied back
offering to help kind of are the
co-founders oh you mean like literally
the the the people
that four will form to be the the
founders co-founders of the community
the algorithm i like how you call it the
algorithm yeah um
and so
what happened uh was that uh
these
um
like especially as the projects got
really big like there started to be a
lot of this kind of infighting and there
are a lot of like i
wanted the thing to be a non-profit and
some of them wanted to be a for-profit
um and then
there started to be people who were just
kind of totally unable to work with each
other there
were
people that were kind of trying to get
an advantage for themselves in a lot of
different ways and
this uh
just
about six months later led to this big
governance crisis and then we kind of
reshuffled leadership a bit
and then uh the project kept on going
then nine months later there was another
governance crisis and then there was a
third governance crisis and
so is there a way to
if you're looking at the human side of
things
is there a way to optimize this aspect
of the cryptocurrency world it seems
that there is
from my perspective there's a lot of
different characters and personalities
and egos and like you said uh
i don't know if
you know i also like just think that
most of the world most of the people in
the world are well intentioned
but the way those intentions are
realized may perhaps come off as uh
yeah as as negative like what uh
is there is there a hopeful message here
about creating a governance structure
for cryptocurrency that uh where
everyone gets along
and after about four rounds of reshuffle
i think we've actually
come up with something that seems to be
pretty stable and happy
um
i think
i mean
i definitely do think that most people
are well intentioned i just think that
like
one of the reasons why i like
decentralization is just because there's
like
this thing about power where power
attracts people with egos and so that
just allows a very small percentage of
people to just ruin so many things you
think ego has a
you think
ego has a use like is ego always bad
it seems like it sometimes does but then
the ethereum research team i feel like
we've found
also kind of a lot like a lot of very
good people that are just
and if primarily you're just interested
in things for the technology
and uh
you know things seem to just
generally be going quite well
yeah when you're when the focus and the
passion is in the tech so on the so
that's the human side of things but the
technology side like what have you
learned what have been the biggest
challenges of bringing ethereum to life
on the technology side
so i think first of all just uh
you know there's like
the first law of software development
which is that when someone gives you a
timetable let's switch the unit of time
to the next largest unit of time and had
one and like we basically fell victim to
that
um and uh
and so
instead of taking those like three
months it ended up taking like 20 months
to watch the thing
um
and that was just i think
underestimating the sheer technical
complexity of the thing
um there are research challenges like so
for example
one of the things that we've been saying
from the start that we would do one is a
switch from a proof-of-work to a
proof-of-stake uh more proof of stake is
to this uh alternative consensus
mechanism where instead of uh
having to waste a lot of uh computing
power on solving these mathematical
puzzles that don't mean anything you
kind of prove that you have access to
coins inside of the system and this uh
and it gives you some level of
participation in the consensus can you
maybe elaborate on that a little bit i
understand the idea of proof of work
um
i know that a lot of people say that the
idea of proof of stake is really
appealing can you maybe linger on a
longer explain what it is
sure
so
basically the idea is like
if i kind of lock up a hundred coins
then i turn that into a kind of quote
virtual miner and the system itself kind
of
automatically and randomly assigns that
in a virtual miner the right to create
blocks at particular intervals and then
if someone else has 200 coins and they
walk on the lock there's 200 coins then
they get a kind of twice as big virtual
miner they'll be able to create their
blocks twice as often right so
it tries to kind of do similar things to
proof of work except instead of the
thing and
rate limiting your participation being
your ability to crank out uh solutions
to kind of hash challenges the thing
that really limits your participation is
kind of how much coins you're locking
into this mechanism
okay so interesting so that that limit
of participation doesn't require you to
run a lot of compute
does that mean that the
richer you are
so rich people
um
are more
like their identities more
right and this stable
yeah verifiable or whatever whatever the
right terminology is
right and this is definitely a common
critique i think my usual answer to this
is that like proof of work is even more
of that kind of system exactly yeah
because i didn't mean it and that
statement is a criticism i think you're
exactly right that's equivalent the
proof of work is the same kind of thing
but in the proof of work you
have to also use physical resources
yes and uh burn computers and burn trees
and all of that stuff is there um a way
to mess with the system of the proof of
uh proof of stake
there is but you will once again need to
have uh a very large portion of all the
coins that are locked in the system to
do anything bad got it
so yeah and just to that maybe take a
small tangent one of the criticisms of
cryptocurrencies the fact
that it gets for the proof-of-work
mechanism you have to use so much energy
in the world yes
is that one of the motivations of
proof-of-stake is to move away from this
definitely like what's your sense of the
uh maybe i'm just under-informed is
there like legitimately environmental
impact from this
yeah uh so
the latest thing was that bitcoin
consumed as much energy as the country
of austria or something like that yeah
and then ethereum is like right now
maybe only like half an order of
magnitude smaller than bitcoin
i've heard you talk about uh ethereum
2.0 so what's the
what's the dream of a theorem 2.0 what's
the
status of proof of stake is the
mechanism that ethereum moves towards
and also how do you move to a different
mechanism of consensus
within a cryptocurrency
so ethereum 2.0 is a collection of
major upgrades that we've wanted to do
to ethereum for quite some time the two
big ones uh one is proof of stake and
the other is that we call sharding
sharding solves another problem with
blockchains which is a scalability
and what sharding does is it basically
says
instead of every participant in the
network having to personally download
and verify every transaction every
participant in the network only
downloads and verifies a small portion
of transactions
and then you kind of randomly distribute
who gets how much work um and because
this of how the distribution is random
it still has the property that you need
a large portion of the entire network to
corrupt what's going on inside of any
shard but
the system is still kind of very
redundant and very secure that's
brilliant
how hard is that to implement and how
hard is uh proof of stake to implement
like on the technical level yeah
software level proof of stake and
charting are both challenging um might
say sharding is a bit more challenging
the reason is that proof of stake is
kind of just a change to like how the
consensus lawyer works
shorting does both that but it's also a
change to the networking layer um the
reason is that charting is kind of
pointless if at the networking layer you
still do what you do today which is you
kind of gossip everything which means
that if someone publishes something
every other node in the client hears it
like from uh on the networking layer and
so instead we have to have enough sub
networks and the ability to quickly
switch between sub networks and other
sub networks talk to each other and this
is all doable but it's a
more complex architecture and it's
definitely the sort of thing that has
not yet been done in cryptocurrency so
most most of the networking layer
in uh cryptocurrency is you're shouting
you're like broadcasting messages and
this is more like ad hoc networks like
yeah you're shouting within smaller
groups smaller group but do you have
like a bunch of subnet like exactly and
you have to switch between oh man i'd
love to see the
uh so it's a beautiful idea
uh so from a graph theoretic perspective
but
just the software like who's responsible
is the ethereum
project like the people involved would
they be implementing like what's the
actual you know this is like legit
software engineering
uh
who like how does that work how do
people collaborate build that kind of
project is this like almost um
like is there a a software engineering
lead is there
is like is it a legit almost like
large-scale open-source projects there
is yeah so um we have uh someone named
danny ryan on our team who's just been
brilliant and great all around and he is
a kind of
de facto kind of development coordinator
i guess it's like you have to invent job
titles for this stuff right the reason
is that um
like we also have this unique kind of
organizational structure where the
ethereum foundation itself kind of does
research in-house but then the actual
implementation is done by independent
teams that are separate companies and
they're located
all around the world and like fun places
like australia um and
so you know you kind of just need a
bunch of kind of almost non-stop cat
hurting to just keep getting these
people to kind of talk to each other and
kind of implement the spec make sure
that everyone agrees on
what's going on and kind of how to
interpret different things
so how far into the future are we from
these two mechanisms in ethereum 2.0
like what's what's your sense of the
timeline
keeping in mind
the previous comments you made about the
sort of uh general
curse of software projects
so ethereum 2.0 is split into three
phases so phase zero just creates a
proof of stake network and it's actually
separate from kind of proof of
the proof of work network at the
beginning just to kind of give it time
to grow and improve itself do people get
to choose sorry to interrupt the people
get to choose i guess yes
they get to choose to move over if they
want to then phase one adds sharding but
it only adds sharding of and of data
storage and not sharding of a
computation and then after that there is
kind of the merger phase which is where
the yeah
and if the accounts uh kind of smart
contracts like all of the activity on
the the existing ether1 system just kind
of gets cut and pasted into eth2 and
then the proof of work chain gets
forgotten and then and the things all
the things that we're living there
before you just kind of continue living
inside of the proof of stake system
so
for timelines um
phase 0 has been
kind of
almost fully implemented
and now it's just a matter of
a whole bunch of security auditing and
testing
um my own experience is that right now
it feels like we're at about a phase
comparable to
when we were doing uh the original
ethereum launch when we were maybe about
four months away from lunch
but that's just a hunch then that's just
that's just a hunch yeah
so how you know it took it took like
over a decade for people to move from
python to python three
how do you see
the move from like at this phase of zero
of
for for different consensus mechanism do
you see there being a
a drastic phase shift and people just
kind of jumping to this better mechanism
so in phase zero i don't expect too many
people to
do much because in phase zero and phase
one the new chain negative deliberately
enough doesn't have too much
functionality turned on it's there just
like if you want to be a proof of stake
validator you can get things started if
you want to store data for other
blockchain applications you can get
started
but existing applications will largely
keep living on each one and then
when the merger happens then the merger
as they
operation that happens all at once
i mean so instead of one of the benefits
of i can sense a system that like on the
one hand you have to coordinate the
upgrade but on the other hand the
upgrade can be coordinated
so what's casper ffg by the way um
casper ffg is the consensus algorithm
that we are using for the proof of stake
is there something interesting uh
specific about casper ffg like some
beautiful aspect of it that's uh there
he is so casper ffg
combines together kind of two different
schools of like it's not algorithm
design uh so the general two different
schools of the of the design are right
one is uh
50 fault tolerant but dependent on
network synchrony so fifty percent
volume fault tolerant but it didn't
tolerate up to fifty percent of faults
but not more but it depends on an
assumption that all of the nodes can
talk uh talk to each other within some
of a limited period of time like if i
send the message you'll receive it
within a few seconds
um and the second the school is
33 fault tolerant but safe under
asynchrony which means that like if we
agree on something then that thing is
finalized and even if the network goes
horribly wonky the second after that
thing is finalized there's no way to
revert that thing
um
and
that's
fascinating how you would make that
happen it's uh definitely quite clever
um i'd recommend the casper ffg paper um
if you just search like archive as in
like a rx iv and casper ffg it's that's
an archive the paper is an archive yeah
yeah who are the authors um myself and
uh virgil griffith
that's awesome
take a small tangent
this idea of just putting out white
papers and papers and putting them on
archive and just putting them publicly
that is that at the core
is that a necessary component of
particular currencies that the tradition
started with uh
uh satoshi nakamoto is like what do you
make of it like what do you make of the
future of that kind of sharing of ideas
i guess so yeah and it's definitely
something that's kind of mandatory for
crypto because like crypto is all about
making
systems where you know you don't have to
trust the operators to trust that the
thing works and so if
anything
behind how a system works is
closed-sourced and that kind of uh kills
the point and so
there is the kind of a sense in which
the
fundamental properties of the category
of the thing we're trying to build just
kind of forces openness but also
openness just has proven to be a really
great way to collaborate and then
there's actually a lot of innovation and
academic collaboration that's just kind
of happened ad hoc in the crypto space
the last few years
so like for example
we have this forum called etheresearch
that's like
e-t-h-r-e-s-e-a-r and then dot c-h um
and
there we publish uh kind of just ideas
in a form that's kind of half formal
like it's halfway in between
like it's it's a kind of a text write up
and then you can have math in it but
it's often much shorter than a paper and
it turns out that the great majority of
new ideas like they're just kind of
fairly small nuggets that you can
explain in like five to ten lines and
they don't really
need the whole formality of a paper
exactly they don't require the kind of
like ten pages of in a filler and so
introduction conclusion is not needed
yeah and so instead you just kind of
publish the idea and then like people
giggle comments on it and it's brilliant
yeah this has been so great for us i
think i interrupted you was there
something else on casper ffg
yeah so just casper ffg is just kind of
combines together these two schools um
and so
basically it creates this system where
if
you have uh more than 50 that are honest
then
um and you have a network synchrony then
the thing kind of goes as a chain but
then if network security fails then kind
of the last few blocks in the chain
might
kind of get replaced but anything that
was finalized by this kind of more
asynchronous process uh gets uh
like can't be reverted and so you
essentially get a kind of best of both
worlds between those two bottles
okay so i know what i'm doing to them
i'm going to be reading the casper
refugee paper uh apologize for the
romanticized question but
what to you are
some or the most beautiful idea in the
world of ethereum
just something uh surprising something
beautiful
something powerful yeah i mean i think
the fact that money can just emerge out
of a database if enough people believe
in it i think is definitely one of those
things that's up there
um
i think one of the things that i really
love about ethereum is also this concept
of composability so this is the idea
that like if i build an application on
top of ethereum then
you can build an application that talks
to my application and you don't even
need my permission you you don't even
need to talk to me right so one really
fun example of this is there was this
center game on ethereum uh called a
cryptokitties that just involved kind of
breeding digital cats yes and someone
else created a game called crypto
dragons where the way you play crypto
dragons is you have a dragon and you
have to feed it cryptokitties
and
they just
created the whole thing just like as an
ethereum contract that you would send
these uh these tokens that are defined
by this other ethereum contract and for
the interoperability to happen like the
projects didn't don't really need to
like the teams don't really need to talk
to each other you just kind of interface
with
the existing program so it's uh
arbitrarily composable in this kind of
way so you have different uh
different groups that could be working
so you could see it scaling to just
outside of dragons and kitties it could
be you could build like entire
ecosystems of software
yeah it's kind of weird i mean
especially in the the decentralized
finance space that's been popping up the
last two years there has been a huge
amount of really interesting things
happen as a result of this is it
particular kind of like financial
applications kind of thing
yeah i mean there's like stable coins so
this is a kind of
tokens retain value i'm equal to one
dollar but they're kind of backed by a
crypt uh cryptocurrency um then there's
decentralized exchanges um
so
when as far as the decentralized
exchanges goes up there's this uh
really interesting construction that
has existed for about one one and a half
years now called uniswap
so what unit swap is let's say a smart
contract that holds balances of uh two
tokens we'll call them token a and token
b
and it maintains an invariant that the
balance of token a multiplied by the
balance of token b has to equal the same
value
and so the way that you trade against
the thing is basically like you have
this kind of curve you know like x times
y equals k and yeah before you trade
it's at some points on the curve after
you trade you just like pick some
different any any other points on the
curve and then whatever the delta x is
that's the amount of a tokens you
provide whatever the delta y is that's
the amount of b tokens you get or vice
versa
and that's just and then kind of the
slope
at the current uh point on the curve
kind of is the price um and so
that just is the whole thing and
that just allows you to kind of have
this
exchange for tokens and even if there's
very few participants and the whole
thing is just like so simple and it's
just very easy to set up very easy to
participate in and
it just
provides so much value to people so
and uh
the uh
the fundamental the the the distributed
application infrastructure and allows
that somehow
yes so this is a smart contract meeting
this is all a computer program that's
just running on ethereum smart contracts
too are just fascinating they are
okay
do you think cryptocurrency may become
the main currency in the world one day
so where do you think we're headed in
terms of
the role of currency the structure type
of currency in the world
i definitely expect some fiat currency
is to
continue to exist and continue to be
strong and i definitely expect kind of
fiat currencies to also digitize in
their own way over the next couple of
decades what's fiat currency by the way
oh just like things like us dollars and
like dollars and euros and yen and these
other things and they're sort of backed
by governments yes but i also expect
enough cryptocurrencies to
play a kind of important role in just
making sure that people always have an
alternative if uh fiat currencies start
breaking so like if or
if you're in
you know some at a very high inflation
place like venezuela for example or
if
your
country just kind of gets cut off from
like um cut off from other financial
systems because of like something the
banks do a gift for any kind of
if there's even like some major trade
disruption right or something worse
happens then
like cryptocurrencies are the sort of
thing that just because of their kind of
global neutrality they're just kind of
always there and you can keep using them
it's interesting that you're quite
humble about the possibilities of the
future of cryptocurrency
you don't think there's a possible
future where
it uh becomes the main set of currency
because it feels like fiat it feels like
the centralized
controlled by governments of currencies
limiting somehow maybe my naive utopian
view of the world it's uh and it's
definitely very possible i mean
i think like four
cryptocurrencies being the
main form of uh value to and of work
well
like you do need to have some
[Music]
much more price stability than they have
today and i mean there are now stable
coins and there are kind of cryptic
cryptocurrencies that try to be more
stable than existing things like bitcoin
and ether but
that just is
to me kind of the main challenge do you
think oh that's do you think that's a
characteristic of this just being the
early days it's such a young concept
that 10 years is nothing in the history
of money yeah and i think it's a
combination of two things right one is
um it's uh
it's still early days but the other is a
kind of more durable any kind of
economic problem which is that
like demand for currency is volatile
right because of like
recessions booms changes to technology
lots of things and if people's demand
for how much currency they want to hold
changes
and
if you have a currency that has a fixed
supply then the change in demand has to
be entirely expressed as a change in
value of the currency and so what that
means is that kind of the volatility of
demand becomes entirely translated into
volatility and ahead of prices of things
that dominated in that currency
but if you have a currency where
instead the supply can change and so the
supply can go up when there's more
demand than
you have the supply and of absorbing
more of that volatility and so the price
of the currency would absorb less of the
volatility on that topic so bitcoin does
have a limited supply specific fixed
supply yes uh what's
what's the idea and the ethereum doesn't
but can you clarify
just in the comments you just made is
ethereum qualify to the kind of currency
that you're talking about and being
flexible in the supply and it's a bit
more flexible but kind of the thing that
you would really want is
something that's kind of specifically
flexible
in response to how valuable the currency
is
and
and i'd recommend you to look at stable
coins as well so like things like die
for example that's a new like how do you
spell that dai
and what uh what's stable coins is that
a type of cryptocurrency it is a type of
cryptocurrency it's um a type of
cryptocurrency that's issued by a smart
contract one of these ethereum computer
programs that um where the smart
contract holds a bunch of ether and then
it is basically
like that people deposit and then at
issues die and the reason why people
deposit is because they wants to kind of
go high leverage on their ether and so
it kind of pairs these two sets of users
one that wants stability and one that
kind of wants extra risk together with
each other
and
it basically
creates some
or gives one set of participants a
guarantee that they'll be pa uh that
they have this asset that can that that
can be later converted back into ether
but like specifically out kind of the
one dollar raid and it has some kind of
uh
stabilizing network effects
yeah it has this yeah it has many kinds
of stabilizing mechanisms in it that's
fascinating okay this
this world is awesome technically just
from a scientific perspective it's an
awesome world uh that i i often don't
see from an outsider's perspective what
i often see is kind of
uh
maybe hype and
a little bit if i may say so like
charltonism
and you don't often see at least from an
outsider's perspective the beautiful
science of it and the engineering of it
maybe is there a comment you can make
of
who to follow
how to learn about this world
without being
interrupted by the charlatans and the
hype people in the space
i think you do need to just know the
specific kind of just people to follow
like
there's
and there's all the kind of the
cryptographers and the researchers and
then there's just like
even just the ethereum research crew
like myself you know like dan crowd
danny justin of the other people
and then and if the academic
cryptographers and
like
before um um this today was at stanford
and uh stanford has the center for
blockchain research and of dan bonnet
that's really uh famous and great
cryptographer um
running it and there's a lot of other
people there and there's people working
on like zero knowledge proofs for
example
and
um zuko from uh zcash has kind of one
other person that i yeah
you know respect so i think
if you follow the technology you crawl
along that yeah yeah you just start with
the etherium group and then look at the
academics dave and so on and then just
cautiously expand the network of people
you follow yeah exactly and like if
someone seems too
too self-promotional then just like
remove them is there books
that are
so there's these white papers and we
just discussed about
about ideas being condensed into really
small parts
is there books that are emerging that
are kind of
good uh introductory material so prefer
historical ones and there's like
nathaniel poppers digital gold which is
just about the history of bitcoin
there's like one and then matthew lysing
announced that there's one about the
history of ethereum um for technical
ones and there's andreas antonopoulos as
mastering ethereum
great so um let me ask you sort of uh
sorry to pull back to the
the
idea of governments and decentralized
currency
uh
you know there's a tension between
decentralization of currency and the
power of nations
the power of governments
you um
what's your sense about that tension can
is there some rule for regulation of
currency
yeah is there like is the government the
enemy of digital currency of distributed
currency or can they be
like
cautious friends
i mean i think like
the one thing that people forget is that
it's clearly not entirely an enemy
because i think uh
if uh
there hadn't been so much government
regulation on and if centralized uh digi
like
issuing centralized digital currencies
then like we would be seeing
things with people like google and
facebook and twitter just kind of
issuing them left and right and then
like if that was the case then
decentralized currencies would still
appeal to some people but they
definitely would appeal to less people
than today
so
even in that sense i think it's uh
clearly been kind of more of a help i
just
kind of set the stage for the end of the
existence as a of the sector in some
ways um but
also
and i think some of both you know like
there's definitely things that
governments kind of can do in some cases
have done to
have hurt the spread of uh and of growth
of
of blockchains there's uh things that
they've done to help and they've
in some cases definitely done a good job
of kind of going after fraudulent
projects and they're going after some of
the projects that have some of the kind
of craziest and most misleading
marketing um
there's uh
also the possibility that governments
will end up using blockchains for a lot
of different things like you know
governments yeah i mean they do a lot
more than just regulating right but
there's also
like they have the
identity of records and they have like
property registry is even just their own
currency is like security
lots of different kind of things that
they're operating and
there's even blockchain applications in
a lot of those and they can you know
they can leverage technology do a lot of
good for our societies
it is a little unfortunate that uh
governments often lag behind
in terms of their
acceptance and leverage of technology if
you look at the autonomous vehicle space
ai in general
they're uh they're a few years behind
it'd be nice uh to help them catch up
that's a that's that's
always ongoing problem you uh met
vladimir putin to discuss the
centralized currency here you're born in
uh where were you born columnar it's a
city about 115 kilometers south of
moscow in russia yes
yeah i grew up in moscow
i mean it's vladimir putin is a
central figure in this part of the world
so what was that like meeting or meeting
him
what was that experience like he's
taller in photos than in person
yeah
yeah that's right he's five seven i
think five eight maybe yeah and that's
uh
unfortunately we didn't actually kind of
have too much of a chance to talk to him
like i managed to see him for about one
minute at the end of this meeting
and i did get a chance to see a lot like
some of the other end of government
ministers and like he recommended some
and uh
some of them are
are actually
interested in trying to use some like
blockchains to
look for various government use cases
they're going to have limited corruption
and other things and i have
it's hard to tell from one conversation
kind of what things are genuine and what
things are just like oh watching is cool
let's do blockchain right
but you know when i when i listen to
like uh
barack obama talk about artificial
intelligence
there's certain things i hear where
okay so he might not be an expert in ai
but he know he like actually studied it
carefully enough to think about it like
he internal like uh even if it's just
reading a wikipedia page
like he really thought about what this
technology means did you get a sense
that uh
putin or some of the ministers like
thought about blockchain like thought
about the fundamentals the technology
understand it intuitively or are they
too old school to try to grasp it summer
old school somewhere more new school
it depends it's it's definitely depends
on who you talk to i mean that's an open
question for me for with putin because
putin has said uh i don't know as i said
i've only talked to him for about one
minute so but sometimes you can pick up
sort of insights
as a quick comment there
they're about maybe you can correct me
on this but they're about 3 000
cryptocurrencies being actively traded
yes uh and ethereum is one of you know a
lot of people believe that there will be
the the main cryptocurrency i think
bitcoin is currently still the main
cryptocurrency but
ethereum very likely might become that
the the main one
um is this kind of diversity good in the
crypto world do you see it sticking
around should there should there be a
winner like should there be some
consensus globally around
uh bitcoin or around ethereum like
what's your what's your sense i
definitely think that diversity is good
and i definitely i think also that
there's probably too many people trying
to make separate blockchains of right
now and the numbers should definitely be
greater than one and probably greater
than two or even five uh not three
thousand
not three thousand yeah and also not
even like 40 high quality platforms to
try to do the same thing
there's definitely this range from just
like one person
who
just like wrongly thinks that you can
create a cryptocurrency in like 12 hours
and
doesn't even think about kind of the
community aspects of maintaining it
going to
people
actually trying but only creating a
really tiny one to like scammers to
people like making something that's
actually successful
and
then there's a lot of different
categories of blockchain and you have
project in terms of what it's trying to
do and what applications it's for um and
i think the experimentation is
definitely healthy
if you look at the two worlds there
might be a little bit disjoints but uh
the distributed applications
cryptocurrency and then the world of
artificial intelligence do you see
there's some overlap between these
worlds
that both worry about centralized
control is there some overlap that's
interesting that you think about do you
think about ai much
yeah and i think
definitely had a thought about things
like like the ai and if control problems
and alignment problems and all of those
things do you worry about the
existential threat of ai that's
definitely one of the things i worry
about
they think um
blood
there's a lot of kind of common
challenges because in in both cases what
you're ultimately trying to do is you're
trying to kind of
get a simple system to direct a more
complex system like in the case of uh
these as strong ais the idea would be
that the simple system is people and the
complex system is well whatever
um thing uh the people the people end up
kind of unleashing on the universe
that'll hopefully be a great thing
um and
in the case of blockchains and of the
complex well the simple thing is
the algorithm which is a piece of static
and fully open source code and the more
complex thing is
just
the num all of the different possible
kind of human actors and of the
strategies that they
might end up used to participate in the
network
do you think about your own mortality
like what
you hope to accomplish in your life
oh i definitely i definitely think about
ending my own mortality
so that's if i gave you the option to
live forever would you depends a lot on
what the fine bridge is
i mean you know if it's one of those
things where i'm going to be kind of
like floating through empty space for 10
to the 75 years then no if it's uh
um
forever worth of uh end of having
you know
fulfilling life with uh and if
meaningful with with friends to uh to
spend the time with with kind of
meaningful challenges to
explain
explore and adventure interesting things
to be working on then
i think absolutely
move
that's uh beautifully put live forever
but uh you'd have to check the fine
print um
i think there's no better way to end it
vitalik thank you so much for talking to
us
so exciting to follow your work from the
distance and uh thank you for creating a
revolutionary idea and sticking with it
and building it out and doing some
incredible engineering work and thanks
for talking today yeah thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with vitalik buterin and
thank you to our sponsors expressvpn and
masterclass
please consider supporting the podcast
by signing up to masterclass at
masterclass.com
lex and getting expressvpn at
expressvpn.com
lex pod
if you enjoy this podcast subscribe on
youtube review it with five stars on
apple podcast support it on patreon or
simply connect with me on twitter at lex
friedman
and now let me leave you with some words
from vitalik buterin
the thing that i often ask startups on
top of ethereum is
can you please tell me why using
ethereum blockchain is better than using
excel
and if they can come up with a good
answer that's when you know you got
something really interesting
thank you for listening and hope to see
you
next time
you